first I want to start by saying movies
fantastic thank you you guys really made
me laugh a lot last night um what is it
like for you guys haven't worked
together if I'm not mistaken oh so what
is it like that first time you guys are
gonna sit down and like meet to talk
about a project together and like
feeling each other out you don't I mean
are you that I was nervous we went we
went in your office right first we might
have had lunch yes we did have lunch you
really talk about it that much I think
and then like we sat down to like talk
about it in depth and I think it is like
a real feeling each other out of like do
we want to make the same movie and you
don't want to like be to leaving almost
like I don't want to say too much
because you know what it'd be like oh
this degree like you know you you really
want to see like if left to our own
devices would we have similar tastes and
sensibilities and would we would we want
to work on the same thing and and that
process takes years and years or so like
really get to the ball yeah so we are
you nervous before sitting down for
something like this or are you sort of
just like if it works it works if it
doesn't it doesn't yeah nervous is the
right word I definitely I for me I would
say I really wanted it to work so I was
really hopeful that we wouldn't sit down
and would Seth just explained like have
very different views of what the movie
should be because the script that we
were meeting on is very different from
the script just because it was written
when the country was in a different
place and the world did not look like it
so we knew that there would be a
developmental process behind it so we I
just I was just hoping that we saw I
died on that like I just I really wanted
it to work out big time sure I spoke to
Jonathan and he said his first cut was
like four and a half hours and that he
removed some karaoke scene
that's what I wanted to bring up so he
said that you weren't crazy about doing
karaoke and then it ends up not being in
the movie so that's probably better
right is it worse it's just the
embarrassment is never gonna go yeah and
what isn't better than just knowing it's
out there somewhere knowing that you got
your knowing that you guys had that you
saw that it wasn't your fault that it's
not in the movie it structurally was not
a supported that's what I wanted to
actually address is that he was
explaining to me that the tone basically
changed in the editing room for sure
could you sort of talk about that yeah I
am traumatized that I have enough to
emotionally pull for my next drama
exactly one another Academy that
dramatized so you're welcome I already
got to go but I was curious how the tone
changed but it became a little more
adult I would say and I think I was a
little sillier and we were like oh it
could actually be like the beginning of
the movie it was a started movie so we
want to establish I think a slightly
more like intelligent tone honestly and
it was a little sillier and broader than
the rest of me yeah